what they're telling the American people
and what actually is happening on the
ground are two different stories and
you're hearing it for the the migrants
themselves so that gentleman right there
has been on top of the issue from the
beginning now a live look at lukeville
Arizona a new surge of illegal Crossing
smashing records at the border yet again
uh we recorded more than 12,000
Encounters in a single day this week and
our cameras were capturing long lines of
mostly adult men from all over the world
uh slipping uh through Brakes in the
fence LED there by Smugglers and Bill
malan's been there all week he's live
again in Luke Val Arizona has much
changed today or is it the same pattern
so far Bill good
morning same pattern Bill good uh good
morning to you it's been a wild week
down here in lukeville Border Patrol
needs a lot of help every time they fix
a hole in the border wall Smugglers cut
it elsewhere and there are more mass
illegal Crossings you mentioned those
single adult men Crossing take a look
behind us these guys all waiting for
process coming in from all over the
world see if we can talk to a few of
them real quick sir where are you from
what country India India where do you
want to go in the United States uh
California California what city no know
you don't know yet and why' you decide
to come you want to work work yeah work
gotcha sir where are you from me I'm
from Sagal Sagal you want to you want to
go to New York yeah I I I I I want to go
there and why did you come to the United
States because it's the peace country
and it's is the Democrat also that's why
we want to be here uh to to continue
what we are planning our life because we
see so many people here and the life is
uh is very great did did did you pay
anybody to come here any
Smugglers no I while trying myself
because I was work hard and the things
is very hard to me I tryling so much
then I do my best to see here in uh
America is so much democracy we see all
over in the world that's so here for
opportunity democracy that sort of a
thing anybody else here from Sagal Sagal
Sagal got a few hands raised up where in
the United States do you guys want to go
to what what
cities New York New York Michigan
Michigan where in Michigan for meet my
my my big brother for your brother your
brother's in the US brother sir where do
you want to
go don't speak English no English okay
ESP
dominicanos Philadelphia Philadelphia
okay so you you get a flavor right there
of some of the places these folks want
to go uh we want to show you some video
we shot late yesterday afternoon before
Sunset we talk about those wall breaches
take a look at this there was another
cut in the border wall here in lukeville
you'll see on the right side of your
screen uh illegal immigrants pouring in
through the breach in that wall hundreds
of them end up coming through uh border
patrol overwhelmed in the area you'll
see them start walking down the border
road uh waiting to be processed looking
for Border Patrol to turn themselves in
this sort of thing happens every single
day out here uh a lot of African men
families from Ecuador and Mexico as well
and we'll show you what happened uh once
they got past that border wall area take
a look at this video they got onto the
local Highway out here in lukeville this
is the only road that goes in and out of
lukeville also goes into Mexico to go to
Rocky Point uh and these illegal
immigrants were just walking in the
middle of the highway thankfully there
was no cars or traffic because the Port
of Entry has been closed down out here
but you can see what agents out here
have to deal with day in and day out and
lastly we want to show you what's
happening in San Diego sector take a
look at this Wild video border patrol
releasing these images thermal video
showing another wall incursion down
there by San Isidro they say about 75
people scaled the border wall led by
Smugglers you'll see them coming up and
down one after another and then
eventually you'll see see them all
Gathering and then they go running into
the United States as a large mass the
San Diego sector border patrol saying
human Smugglers are doing this sort of
thing every day down there it's
dangerous for the migrants it's
dangerous for agents but this is
happening all along the southern border
and back out here live just a short time
ago before we came to you guys uh border
patrol had all of these men uh take
trash bags and pick up trash in this
area we're actually in the uh Oregon
Pipe Cactus National Monument that's
what this area is it has been completely
trashed through illegal immigration over
the last couple of weeks uh before these
guys get processed and transported they
gave them trash bags and made them pick
up as much trash as they possibly could
we'll send it back to you so Bill just
just a couple of questions I don't know
if there's an uh able to ask some of
them this but if they're coming from
India and Sagal how did they get to
where they are how did they get to to
South America Latin America and also
what have any of them said to you um
what their credible threat was because
that's the bar for Asylum was for them
in those
countries so for the first question it's
a good one and we've asked them all that
question um a lot of them said they'
flown into South America First either
Colombia or Brazil and then they start
making their way through Central America
one guy from Sagal told us he flew into
Brazil then went to Colombia Nicaragua
Honduras Guatemala then into southern
Mexico tapachula then they ride the
trains up or they take buses and they
get up here to the northern border so
they go through a handful of countries
before they get here to your second
question we've been talking to guys out
here all week long Martha not a single
one of them have told us they plan to
claim Asylum or that they have fear of
their governments or fear of persecution
in their home countries every single guy
out here has told us they're here for
work for opportunity or to link with
family and that again does not qualify
for Asylum Asylum uh law is very strict
in the United States you have to
demonstrate fear of persecution and uh
everybody we've talked to out here so
far says they're here essentially for
work and opportunity uh bill just one
last thing of that given that answer how
many will be
deported it's hard to know but overall
looking at the big picture most will
likely be released into the country with
what's called an NTA a notice to appear
and a future court date a handful of
them may get deported but when we have
guys from like Syria coming in like we
did the other day the US doesn't even
have diplomatic relations with some of
these countries it's not like they can
call it Bashar al- Assad and have them
land in Damascus Airport right so some
of these people are going to be here to
stay some will eventually be removed but
a large majority because of how
overwhelmed border patrol is right now
how over capacity they are they're doing
a lot of mass releases a lot will
probably get NTA notied to appears with
future court dates and sometimes those
court dates are years out in advance uh
Bill we've talked to you every day down
there same location uh good work down
there thank you Bill I'm Steve duy I'm
Brian Kil me and I mean heart and click
here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling
analysis